Trump says Kim jong-un is always just a
phone call away the president talking
more tonight about his summit with the
North Korean leader correspondent
Jillian Turner has the story I have a
good relationship with Kim jong-un
that's a very important thing because I
can now call him I can now say well we
have a problem I told him I gave him a
very direct number he can now call me if
he has any difficulty I can call him we
have communication it's a very good
thing back home three days after the
Singapore summit president Trump's
taking a victory lap highlighting his
own negotiating traps and touting the
status as America's diplomat in chief
people are shocked that this is the kind
of prisoner they thought Trump was gonna
get in he was gonna start throwing bombs
all over the place it's actually the
opposite now convinced he's defied many
of his critics expectations he's
claiming to usher in a new era of peace
when I came into this job it looked like
war not because of me you remember the
sit-down with Barack Obama he said the
biggest problem that the United States
has and by far the most dangerous
problem and he said to me that we've
ever had because of nuclear is North
Korea I have solved that problem his own
Secretary of Defense echoed that
sentiment just a few hours ago the past
does not have to define the future
unquote but while a possible new avenue
to peace now exists with North Korea we
remain vigilant regarding pursuit of
nuclear weapons also taking the
opportunity to deflect blame for serious
civil war on his favorite nemesis when
it's my fault I'll tell you President
Obama by not going across the red line
in the sand that he drew I went across
it with the 59 missile hits but
President Obama when he didn't go across
the red line what he gave away nobody
even knows
but according to president Trump Obama's
not only responsible for North Korea's
nuclear program and the Syrian war
President Obama lost Crimea just so you
understand this was long before I got
there just I want to make it so the
faking is Princeton properly
President Obama lost Crimea he further
explains that Putin invaded Crimea
because President Obama failed to
command respect
a failing that in his eyes Kim Jong on
doesn't have he speaks and his people
sit up at attention I want my people to
do the same someone who definitely
admires Kim's leadership style is
Vladimir Putin he issued a warm
invitation for Kim to visit Russia just
yesterday and when President Trump was
asked about having a meeting of his own
with Putin he told a reporter today at
the White House quote it's possible
Brett Jillian thank you